so there are many fans of Pride and
Prejudice and loads of zombie fans were
you guys nervous having to make a film
that would satisfy both I think
initially like when I first saw the
title I was nervous and I read the
script and I thought it was great once
per started adding the cast I was like
oh this is looking good and then we
started shooting and we shot like our
first fight scene as a group and I said
we saw some of it on the monitor and I
was like oh noes i'm gonna retry it can
you think of any other pieces of classic
literature that could use some zombies
every single one every single one any
Shakespeare novel Romeo and Juliet and
something yummy and Jillian's on yeah
yeah one piece and zombies yeah great
anything you've done and zombie yeah
just throw some zombies yeah yeah you
guys are all playing characters who have
been well established for 200 years but
how does the presence of zombies change
those characters it's kind of changed
their world from what it was in the
original text I suppose they're living
in a different a different time it keeps
the same tone like I guess the sort of
the period but um it sort of added that
little influx of adrenaline that so
maybe something like this leaves every
now and again to sort of reintroduce it
to the world do you think gene Austin
would have been a zombie fan yes I think
so she was really forward thinking for a
time was a she and I think you know it's
a testament to her work did in that it
can kind of stand up to the zombie
apocalypse in it and it's sort of what
she was going for was that Saul
feminists like you know girls saying
driven by them and this is then like
tenfold because the girls provided they
also like you know you'd be the most
badass yeah the back is really cool did
its it easy with you guys in the actual
production or was it did it feel weird
Ashley slashing people apart I love to
you know i loved it i was like
completely Adrenalize by like afterwards
I was like yeah like whoa and this
endless and the city house you're like
ready to go fight scenes are amazing
extremely impressive fighting after
doing this movie who would you say is
the best fighter in the cast Lily no
Bella right there's only one way to
solve this i mean i'm to the desk here
let's go
I shall never relinquish my soul for a
ring the right man you would the right
man wouldn't ask me to wear your Barbie
you
you